>> Lewis was elected as a fellow
of the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences in 2008, and the
Outstanding Achievement Award
from the University
of Minnesota,
and the Harold R. Johnson
Diversity Service Award
from the University of Michigan,
and has earned several
honorary doctorate degrees.
A native of Tidewater Virginia.
>> Whoa! That's my city!
[ Laughter ]
>> Hello to all the
one residents
of Tidewater, Virginia.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
Lewis earned his undergraduate
degree in history and psychology
from Concordia College in
Moore-- Moorhead Minnesota,
and his PhD in history from
the University of Minnesota.
Just in case you are wondering,
in a few minutes
you will realize
that Dr. Lewis' Minnesota accent
is somewhat very different
from my Iowa accent,
a neighboring state.
Dr. Lewis.
[ Applause ]
>> It's actually very nice to
travel the world and realize
that other people have actually
made their way from [inaudible]
to other parts of the
country as well, so salute.
[ Laughter ]
Subra thank you for
that introduction.
I was reminded that yesterday
would have been my mother's
birthday; she passed
away a few years ago.
She would have loved that
introduction, I have to say.
Good morning to you all and I
think it is still good morning.
Good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> Thank you.
We gather this Sunday
morning to salute you,
the Carnegie Mellon
University class of 2016
for staying the course,
overcoming challenges,
setting aside failures,
appropriately accepting
success, and graduating.
This is an awesome
achievement and I'm honored
to share in the moment.
In fact I would like to thank
Subra Suresh, President of CMU
and pro [inaudible], as well
as the Carnegie Mellon
University Board of Trustees
for this wonderful opportunity
to receive an honorary degree
from this spectacular
institution.
My personal relationship
with Carnegie Mellon began
over three decades ago when
my good friend Joe Trotter,
Dr. Joe Trotter, invited me
to speak about my research
on African American migrants.
Inevitably that opportunity
yielded the privilege of serving
on a CMU humanities and social
sciences college review panel,
chairing an external
review committee
for the history department,
and having the chance
to assist Dr. Trotter in
funding and launching CAUSE,
the Center for Africanamerican
Urban Studies and the Economy,
which has just recently
celebrated its 20th
anniversary [cheering].
Yes. That's great.
[ Applause ]
Now I am both humbled and
delighted to speak on behalf
of this year's very diverse
and distinguished class
of honorary degree recipients,
a group that includes,
as you've heard, an acclaimed
stage and screen star
who counts among her
accomplishments an academy
award, a golden globe, and
two Emmys, a television icon
and Emmy award winning writer
and actress whose influenced the
lives of millions of children,
a prolific innovator worth
over 1100 patents worldwide,
and one of the most
successful venture capitalists
in the world.
Graduates make a
note to yourself;
learn more about these folks.
It is also an honor to be
standing here before a group
of students that
have been vetted
by the vigorous academic
standards and requirements
of one of the world's
finest universities.
You have been given the Carnegie
Mellon stamp of approval,
and with it comes
a certain level
of attainment and
responsibility.
Now many years ago,
as you've heard,
I walked across a similar stage
at a small [inaudible] College
in Minnesota to accept
my diploma.
Like many of you, I was
able to join the ranks
of the newly educated because
someone believed in me.
In my case it was started
with my maternal grandmother.
While her dream was deferred
she strategized to ensure
that my dream would
not be denied.
It was the early 20th century
and my grandmother had
saved money, twice,
to attend St. Augustine College
in Raleigh North Carolina.
Each time she did her father
asked her for the money
to save an older brother
from losing his home,
and the sad truth is he lost
that home during the
Great Depression.
A domestic in the
segregated south for most
of her working days my
grandmother reserved her dream
of being educated
by passing it along.
When it came time for my--
for her daughter, my mother,
to graduate from high school
my grandmother sent her first
to the Norfolk Division
of Virginia State,
today's Norfolk State
University.
So my grandmother feared
the demands of living
at home would distract my
mother from her studies
so this god fearing,
church going woman,
played the daily number, or
what was referred to back then
as a poor person's
lottery, and she won.
[ Cheering ]
Even though my grandmother
could have used that money
to ease the burdens of
her own life she st--
she chose instead to send my
mother to St. Augustine College
because she believed
just that fervently
in the transformative
power of education.
When I came along the only
question I was allowed
to entertain was which
college will you attend.
So I stand before you today
because of my grandmother's
determination
to pay a dream forward.
My mother and I inherited
the belief
that the educated
have a responsibility
to pay back the faith
invested in them by working
to in some way improve
the world.
Let's see.
Let's see a show of hands
how many of you have family,
friends, and teachers who
backed and supported you
through your higher education
experience [cheering].
Thank you.
Please join me in recognizing
these special individuals
with a ruckus round of applause.
[ Applause ]
Their job is done.
In fact if you listen
closely you'll hear some sighs
of relief coming from parents
in the audience [laughter].
Now your job, like
mine when I graduated,
is to never confuse the
attainment of an education
with what it means
to be educated.
Graduation marks
a moment in time
when you have assembled
the necessary credits
to earn a degree.
But being educated--
being educated requires you to
deploy the discipline of mind
that comes with the pursuit of
knowledge for the betterment,
not only of yourself
and your family,
but also the greater society.
I graduated in the
post-Vietnam era of gas lines,
student protests, and
racial desegregation.
I knew what had been and what
was happening at the time
but I had no idea what to expect
in the years and
decades to come.
For example, in 1978 it
was nearly impossible
to conceive a desktop
computers, much less a world
so completely integrated
with powerful personal computing
ability that resides in a phone.
Just think about that.
It hasn't been that long ago.
Back then when I imagined the
future I pictured a world akin
to the Jetsons.
There are people in
this audience old enough
to remember the Jetsons
[laughter].
A prime time animated series
that predated the Simpsons
by almost 30 years.
Its world was populated
with space age families,
sassy robots, and flying cars.
Computers delivered
both instant meals
and instantaneous
medical diagnosis,
and cures for diseases were
just one individually formulated
pill away.
Flash forward to today and
flying cars are still a matter
of fantasy but we
aren't that far away
from a semi-autonomous
automobile.
Gene mapping is almost common
place in the development
of customized treatment plans.
Robotics is now offered
as part of the curriculum
in many high schools
across the United States.
And artificial intelligent
protocols such as IBM
to Watson regularly beat humans
at games of knowledge and logic.
It is said that at CMU you
do not imagine the future,
you create it.
But indulge me for
a few seconds.
Look ahead graduates.
Look ahead to 25 years from now.
What do you see?
Marriage, children, sadly maybe
divorce, and success [laughter].
It's true.
But what about on
the technology front?
Will it be that the discipline
of robotics has ushered
in a new age of productivity
and profitability;
a world where artificial
intelligence alters the makeup
of a work as well as the
composition of a work force.
Today a single retailer can
employ nearly 100,000 people
around the nation
to move product
from regional sites
to consumer homes.
There is, however, speculation
that robots could replace
these workers in short order;
not next year but tomorrow.
What happens then?
Do we simply shrug
and acknowledge
that progress always
comes at a price
or do we examine
the broader social
and economic implications?
Graduates, many of you will
certainly be the architects
of the next technological
revolution,
but while you are developing
devices and programs
that enhance efficiency,
and perhaps even save lives
you must also simultaneously
challenge yourselves to solve
the impact of these advances.
As our economy shifts away
from human based work--
from a human based workforce
to machine driven labor
will you make accommodations
for the newly technologically
disenfranchise?
Undoubtedly CMU has prepared you
to meet the exponentially
increasing technological demands
of a growing global economy
in a more environmentally
conscious manner.
But what additional tools
and insights might you need
to be both successful
contributors
and successful global citizens?
Twenty-five years from now
will the courses that you took
in history, philosophy, and
literature, your experimentation
with theatre and the arts, or
your interdisciplinary courses
and studies-- and study abroad
prove just as useful as the work
that made you a student
of science, math,
and engineering or not?
For those of you in the arts and
the humanities will the value
of your degree decrease in
a technology focused world
or increase because
people with your background
and training are
suddenly in short supply?
It is critical that all of you
envision yourselves as part
of the creative society which
produces creative solutions.
So historically we have looked
at those coming out of the arts
and the humanities to help
us transform what we know
and how we know it.
Today engineering, math,
and computer science
have truly evolved
into creative disciplines.
More people worldwide
are familiar with Siri
than any book, play, or essay
written in the last 100 years.
The engineers and technologists
at Apple have created something
that has infiltrated our
consciences like few other works
of art ever have, and that's
actually important to think
about and dwell on and think
through the implications.
Yet science, engineering, and
math alone are not enough.
Case in point, 9/11.
Despite the utilization of
very sophisticated machinery
and highly skilled
technicians we failed
to intercept the terrorists
because 9/11 had more to do
with religion and ideology
than with probes, drones,
and surveillance devices.
Similarly, engineers
successfully built a well
in a West African
village not to long ago
to ensure a ready supply of
clean water, yet fail to take
into consideration broader
cultural implications.
To their surprise the women
who haul the water continue
to walk all the way to the
river despite the risk.
When questioned
by anthropologists
the women explain
that no one had asked them
where to build a well.
You see, the hauling of the
water had a social function
as well as a utilitarian one.
The women used the time
to socialize and get away
from their children and
the men folk [laughter].
Both of these examples
serve as a powerful reminder
that studying a multiplicity
perspectives has real worth
when we're trying to
solve real problems.
Human interaction, as we
all well know, is messy.
It's not always scientifically
based
or mathematically
predictable, nor is it linear.
Sometimes you simply
cannot get from point a
to point b in a straight line.
This is to suggest that the
world is complex and the issues
that we face are indeed
complex, and it requires
that technologists consult
with social scientists
that humanist work with
engineers and that scientists
and artists collaborate
to solve problems
and try new possibilities.
Graduates as we move forward
in life and as you move forward
in life you must strive to be
in conversations across lines
of difference, exchange
insights and ideas in a profound
and noble way with people of
different racial, academic,
and social economic backgrounds.
Luckily today's technologies
eclipse--
eclipse time and distance making
it possible for you to connect
in real time with people in
different geographic zones
across the United States
and around the world.
You will also need to recognize
the importance of being embedded
in community and
actively working
to improve the American
form of democracy.
That's not just about
voting; it's about the ways
in which we think about
the opportunity for all
and actually being able
to gather information
across a broad spectrum of
media that will allow you
to fashion your understanding
of a world.
Or to put it bluntly, to be
able to tell the difference
between garbage and
the real stuff.
Now if this election cycle
is a harbinger of things
to come successfully
stored in the garbage
from the real stuff
will become the hallmark
of an enlightened citizen.
Yeah we can think about
that for a second.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
And this would be true
whether you were in Berlin,
Beijing, or Birmingham.
You must remember to ask why,
to research independently,
to pursue truth, and to affirm
your commitment to honest,
integrity, and the common good.
Now look to the future once
more, to your 25th reunion.
This time what do you see?
More changes
in the technological
landscape, greater diversity?
How about improved
connectedness?
Hopefully you see your future
selves as inextricably linked
to the Amer-- to America and the
world, both the opportunities
and the challenges because you
have [inaudible] from either.
Keep looking.
Are you a key player in
the creation of a new
and technologically
responsible golden age?
Are you balancing your desire
to create bigger, better,
faster with the need to sustain
a healthy and vibrant economy
in which all members
have a stake?
More specifically, are you the
leader that Carnegie Mellon
as prepared you to become or
are you merely participating
in the creation of
cool new stuff?
I challenge you.
I challenge you because you
are the best and the brightest,
as you've heard and you will
hear no doubt many more times
over the course of this
day and the next few days.
So graduates of 2016 stand up.
[ Applause ]
And I would ask that
you repeat after me.
We the 2016 graduating
class of Carnegie Mellon.
>> We the 2016 graduating
>> Will do the unimagined.
>> We will discover
the undiscoverable.
>> We will change the world.
>> Responsibly.
>> Let's try that one more time.
We will change the
world responsibly.
>> We will change the
>> And then one more time.
We will change the
world responsibly.
>> We will change the
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
You may sit down.
If you remain faithful
to this moment
in time you will have done
far more than earn a degree.
You will have used your
skills, talents and intellect
for the benefit of all.
I am confident that you
understand the significance
and I am grateful to
have had this opportunity
to see you off on your journey.
I'm truly excited for you.
I'm excited for the world
and I extend my sincerest
congratulations.
Do well graduates and
do good because you can.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]